you can't plan your life 30 years ahead
you don't need to and i think that's a
pressure that we put on ourselves like
oh my god what am i doing what am i
doing when i'm 50 and it's like well
actually hopefully you'll be doing
something that surprises you
and why not just let your life surprise
you constantly why make it out like life
is like linear perfect journey we're
like at 30 i'm going to do this and i'm
40. i'm going to do this and at 50 and
it's like well life probably is not
going to go like that and that picture
that you have rolling
because it won't fit in with what you're
experiencing
that gap is the pressure that you feel
in your life
the reason i'm saying don't put purpose
on a pedestal
is because then purpose becomes this
heavy weight that you're carrying
and you're now like
judging yourself that you don't know it
and if you instead make your goal to
learn about purpose learn about meaning
explore yourself experiment grow now it
becomes like
oh i'm just experimenting i'm just
learning about myself
if you don't really have an interest
it's going to be really hard and when it
comes to our soft skills we go oh i'm a
good communicator i'm just going to
stick to that forget vulnerability or
i'm a really good talker forget
listening
and that kind of all comes in together
and i think the point is that if we're
always learning and figuring out a way
to serve in whatever situation we're in
that's that's the best route for success
because that's something that no one can
take away from you we like stress out
about not being motivated we stress out
by not finding purpose but guess what
just like you've got to eat and shower
you have to find purpose in every day
i think that we have to get as intimate
with our dark side as possible and i
feel like when you don't get that
intimacy you don't really understand it
i look back and i think why did i do
that and it's just always been my desire
to experiment always been my desire to
learn always been my desire to be
curious and find out more about myself
the first is to approach any situation
with compassion and empathy the other
thing is to recognize that sometimes
when we go through pain
it makes us pay attention
like when we go through pain it makes us
pay attention when things are going
great we often get complacent
we stop worrying we get lazy we don't
worry about anything we're just relaxing
and as soon as you feel pain
pain is a way of your body of society of
the economy to force you to pay
attention so if you're being lazy and
not eating right your body reacts badly
to tell you to stop doing that so any
pain that happens in your life first of
all is saving you from more pain
and so for me that's the shift that we
have to go through and that all comes
from us
deeply looking into our minds and going
where are these blocks turning up from
where are they coming from what are
their roots and then how can i replace
them with
the the right conversation the right
dialogue internally when it comes to
your hard skills focus on your strengths
when it comes to your soft skills focus
on your weaknesses if you do those two
things your life will change
dramatically because if you're good at
something you'll become exceptional at
it need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
jay shetty and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two embrace life's
challenges
life is challenging it's full of ups and
downs
we think i wish things could just be
still
i wish things would stop changing
i wish my problems would go away
we want a life that's steady with a path
that's flat
yet as deborah evans once said
life is like an ekg
without the ups and downs
you're not living
because this is what a flat line looks
like
and this is what a lifeline looks like
when we feel those highest highs those
extreme peaks we're ecstatic to be on
the summit
then when we're in the lowest lows those
deep values we're ready to submit
and so we try and play it safe and avoid
all risks
but when we seek security and prioritize
passiveness
we don't realize that a flat lifeline
means we're dead
if we're always trying to live our lives
at sea level then we'll never see what
life is truly about
that what we judge as good and bad
are in fact deeply connected
how could we ever experience how
wonderful happiness is
if we never felt sadness
how could we taste the triumph of
success
if we never failed how could we know the
comfort of gratitude
if we never experienced loss
somehow we got the idea that being
successful and moving forward in life
means we're constantly moving up
but have you ever read a book watched a
movie or seen a case study like that
they don't exist
every story worth telling has peaks and
valleys successes and setbacks
our brains are wired for novelty when
something's new whether it's a fantastic
surprise or a huge challenge our brains
light up we thrive on learning and our
opportunities to grow yet our brains
also easily become accustomed to
patterns making it harder for us to
change
dramatic disruptions help us break these
patterns and invite us to see and
experience the world in a whole new way
and as it turns out we're designed for
change all the way down to ourselves
your body is constantly being reinvented
replacing most of itself every 7 to 15
years even down to our bones
the universe is constantly shifting and
we are part of that when we try and
resist change it goes against our very
nature
in the journey of life we experience
pleasure and pain there will be sunshine
and rain there will be loss in gain but
we must learn to keep moving forward
again and again so if you open your eyes
this morning
if you were healthy enough to move about
to maybe get yourself some food
if you were able to go to a refrigerator
and find that it was full and stocked if
you were able to put on some clothes
and if you had a roof over your head
just remember how grateful you can be
for all those things we consider to be
basic
but for others
they don't even have access to
we can't stop life's ups and downs but
we can change how we experience them
we can learn to go with life's flow
because as helen keller once said
life is either a daring adventure
or nothing at all rule number three do
something you love whenever you give out
any energy
love
hate
anger
kindness
you will always get it back
one way or another
love is like a circle
whatever love you give out
it always comes back to you
i was just showing
sally a facebook memory backstage
seven years ago
i love facebook reminders look at it
showed me that i was speaking to this
little group of students
about seven mistakes people make in
their twenties
and it was a memory of a talk that i was
giving six and seven years ago i
released my first video five years ago
so six and seven years ago most people
didn't know who i was and what i was
doing i had an event in london
called conscious living it was on a
friday night in the city
and five to ten people would show up
every week that's it five to ten people
and i remember loving it and i remember
feeling so happy and so grateful that
five to ten people showed up and i feel
the same way about the first five to ten
people that followed me and commented on
my videos and i feel the same way about
the first five to ten people when i
finally got to meet them and i found
that
if you can love
one person if you can deeply feel
grateful for one person
then hot thousands hundreds of thousands
millions will come from that but if you
struggle to be present and connected to
that one person
it's really hard
to be trusted by the universe with more
what is it that success looks like for
you and don't make it about a number
don't make it about an account of views
don't make it about a follower don't
make it about a size of home because
those things
are great for success
but they're not great for happiness
my measure of success is
can i wake up and do something i love
every day rule number four never doubt
yourself i think we've come to a place
where we feel that
freedom
and the freedom of unlimited choice
is power
and we've all realized and the science
and the studies all show this that the
more choice we have the worst mistakes
we make and we make poorer decisions
based on this complete limitless choice
and i found that actually when you
stripped away some of that choice
your ability to make decisions grew my
meditation teacher said to me even in a
shallow dive you get wet so still do it
beautiful
i love it
the first step
is learning
to appreciate where you are
because if we can't appreciate where we
are
we will never appreciate where we get to
and i often say to people like you're
exactly where you need to be
and we're scared of accepting that
because you're like well i don't like
being here but that's because we don't
see it as part of our story and then the
third part of it truly
is that i've seen the most powerful
dreams
be linked to service
and impact
and so when your dream expands into
having a service element
you get the opportunity to work harder
than you've ever dreamed of you're able
to learn things that you never believed
you could because we're so phenomenal at
extending ourselves
beyond what we know for people that we
love and people we want to serve also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five appreciate every
person in your life i think one of the
biggest mistakes i've made
and i think we make as humans is we
often look for
divinity in humanity
you're looking for that divine person
that has all the answers and that is
infallible and perfect
and when you seek divinity in humanity
you're left with
insecurity and anxiety
because no one fulfills that divine
search and so for me what i really had
to understand as i went down that road
and felt like i was let down and felt
like people
made me feel unworthy or unequipped was
i recognized that there were four
pillars of relationships
and they are care
competence
consistency and character
every single person in your life
is going to be able to give you or
should be able to give you at least one
of these four characteristics
very rarely if ever will one person give
you all four
and if you're lucky you might have a few
people in your life that give you two or
three so let's talk about each of them
care
my mom there is no one in the world who
cares for me more than my mom she would
do anything for me she'd be there for me
all she wants to make sure
doesn't matter what i've achieved or
what i've done if she picks up the phone
to me her first question is have you
eaten
what did you eat
uh are you safe are you healthy right
like that's all she cares about
now my mum isn't the person that i go to
for business advice
or she's not the person i'm saying
hypothetically that i go to for social
media advice that's not her competence
but she doesn't need to be she cares for
me and that's what i get from her now
let's go to competence
if i'm thinking about
starting a business
new dragon over here
right like you'd be a great friend to
call up you're someone who understands
what it takes to get investors scale a
business build teams manage
internationally grow scale sell like you
have that journey and you have that
network you have that career i'd also
care about you i know you also care
about me so i've got two out of four in
you and you've got good character you
don't have the consistency though
because we don't see each other enough
so
so three out of four 35 yeah 75 percent
and so for that for me is that perfect
example of there's competence there and
there is care there which is wonderful
and there's character there i believe
you're someone of good character and
that's the next one character there are
some people in our life that hold us to
higher values
they help us grow with greater integrity
they help us see things beyond what
we're chasing they make us look beyond
our desires and make us recognize that
there's so much more to life
and those people are massively important
and those people may not be the people
we see every week they may not be the
people we see every day they may not be
the people that we call up but you need
them as your compass the people with
character are your compass
and then finally you have the people
that are consistent you have some mates
that you just know are always going to
pick up the phone
you know that if you need to move house
you've got a family emergency you know
which friend you call
they may not be the competent business
advisor
they may care about you but they don't
care about you as deeply as your mom
does but they are consistently always
there for you
and that's beautiful but the problem is
when we look at our consistent friend we
think why are you not competent we look
at our competent friend we think why
don't you have good character we look at
our character friend and say well why
aren't you always there and so we're
always looking for which c they don't
have
rather than appreciating for them for
exactly what they bring to our life rule
number six become more self-aware on a
mental level what's self-awareness
knowing what type of people i like to be
with knowing who helps me grow and who
drains me that's mental self-awareness
so self-awareness at every level and
then we go into the spiritual
consciousness level
that's disconnecting from all these
identities and understanding the
identity that we are wired for
generosity and we're wired to serve and
only in service can we be happy
and that's us on a consciousness level
that's the identity of consciousness
like water is wet the sun is heating in
light
consciousness is service
like that's how it fits why are we wired
for that we're wired for that because
all of us
as consciousness have been designed and
we see it since like even kids
like i was giving this example of
this beautiful and you may have seen it
it is it went viral on instagram it was
this
little girl probably two years old
watching a cartoon
and she takes a handkerchief and the
cartoon character's crying
and she goes up to the television and
she tries to wipe it off
right and it's it's incredible because
this girl's two years old and she thinks
this cartoon character animal is crying
and she gets a real tissue and tries to
wipe it on the tv obviously it doesn't
work and there's another another one
that i saw with this statue of this
rabbit and there's like four rabbits and
one rabbit's like falling off the end
and this little boy is trying to push
the rabbit up but it's a stone rabbit
it's just a statue but he's trying to
help it back up so we see and there's a
great article in wired about this about
how we're wired for generosity our brain
is happier in service this whole world
is almost a school
an education system to make us realize
that one truth and we see
that when we're serving when we're doing
that we feel genuine happiness but when
we're trying to gain and greed and power
and strength
we even feel empty as it slips through
our fingers
so the why
is because that allows us to connect to
our deepest self
the happiest self that we have and
modern studies have shown that so
michael norton at cambridge university
he did a study where they gave people
five ten twenty dollars to spend on
themselves have you seen this go ahead
yeah and then they spent five ten twenty
dollars on others
so people spent five ten twenty dollars
on makeup starbucks and normal stuff
right right that was the that was the
three comments three makeup starbucks
and then something else i can't remember
and then people who spent on other
people they also bought others the same
stuff starbucks was still in there and
they're buying all this stuff what they
found is that when people self-assess
their happiness before and after without
knowing about this a b test
people who spent the money on themselves
didn't feel any happier or any less
happier
but the people that spent on others felt
10 to 20 percent happier
and then he went and tried this out this
was a college in in the united states
that then when it did in africa they did
it all over the world and the stats and
the patterns are the same that we're
wired for generosity we're wired to
serve to make us realize that that's our
real nature that's our greatest
self-awareness rule number seven be of
service to others i'd say that
in in my heart and my intention
i've only wanted to do good for others
and serve others and support others so
whenever i even when i started creating
content or even when i worked in the
city or when i became a monk
my intention was always to serve and to
help others my intention was never
motivated by
uh big results or anything that's
happened in my life today i never
thought it would happen and and i never
even believed that that was the goal or
that was the reason i was doing it the
reason i was doing it was i believed
that i uncovered this incredible wisdom
and i wanted to share it that was it and
so i think sometimes our intention gets
uh dirty or messy
uh sometimes really our intention is ego
driven or sometimes it's uh money driven
or sometimes it's results driven and
none of those things are bad you can
have money you can be famous you can be
successful but if that is your reason
for doing it if that is your intention
for doing it it won't satisfy you even
if you get there
and actually if you do it for a deeper
reason you'll probably get there faster
and you'll be happier when you actually
receive it and so one thing for me is
and i work on this every day it's not
that i've mastered it but every day i'm
working on my intention to always be of
service to always want to help rule
number eight meet incredible people i
was really fortunate to meet incredible
people when i was young i met a few
people that absolutely transformed my
life
i'm eternally indebted to them grateful
to them and
i owe it all to them and so i give all
my success to them you know without
meeting
those amazing mentors and those
phenomenal thought leaders and thinkers
who are not famous who are not known who
are not
present like they're not they're not in
the social media world they're not big
names or whatever
those people you know those people
if i never met them none of this would
have happened i can see that's the
emotion in your face when you say this
yeah i just i i really you know we
skipped it earlier but i i just feel
like
the gratitude that i have for
people who saw potential in me when i
didn't see it myself
that is just the greatest gift you can
give to someone like i today have
self-awareness and i have confidence and
i know who i am and i i wasn't always
like that like there were tons of years
where i was insecure and
you know i was bullied for being
overweight and i was bullied for being
the only indian at school and there was
so much like baggage to do with just
my body my how the language i used and
all this kind of stuff and to to have
someone notice that you may have
something
i mean you've had that and that is just
you you like honor that person for the
rest of your life and the best thing is
those people don't even want it so you
know the best thing about all of this is
the people there are not going oh yeah
we did that they're actually saying no
no it's not us like it's you and and i
think that's the beauty of that so i i
have to say that i it's important that i
share that answer not because i'm trying
to
give a more strategic answer but i think
it's important because it is a big part
of it
and so that would be the monks that i
met it would be the coaches that i met
the guys that i met looking at it from a
very practical strategic standpoint
shifting now
[Music]
my parents forced me to go to public
speaking and drama school when i was 11
years old
and
i really didn't want to go because i was
shy
i was unconfident i was insecure about
being on stage or being in a public
setting i actually loved acting growing
up i really enjoyed acting and doing
theater and things like that where i was
playing another character but being
myself on stage
that was the last thing i wanted to do
and my parents saw that and they saw
that as something that i should work on
so they forced me and my school to
enroll me in a public speaking course
so from the age of 11 through to the age
of 18
for three hours a day three days a week
so nine hours a week for seven years i
went to public speaking school really
for seven years of my life i went to
public speaking school
so when i look back at my ability to
communicate my ability to understand
ideas and by the way public speaking
school is examination based too so we
had exams where they would give you a
topic 15 minutes before you have 15
minutes to research a topic from the
books in the room that they give you
because there was no smartphone at the
time when we were 11 12 years old
and you'd have to create a speech in 15
minutes about that subject from the
books that were in the room you had to
read from a book that you'd never read
before they'd pick a random page and
they'd ask you to read it out so the
examination of a public and this was at
the london academy of music drama and
arts it's called lambda
and that's where i studied for seven
years so
that's a very strategic skill set that i
had the time to develop thanks to my
parents you know like without my parents
that none of that would have ever
happened and i think that's a big part
of why people
hopefully appreciate how i communicate
ideas because i've spent a lot of time
understanding communication
but when i was 18 i had nothing to talk
about
so even though i had all these tools and
skills i didn't really use them because
i didn't care about anything so sure i
gave a good presentation at university
and work experience and an internship
but it was never something that brought
me to life
and so then when i met the monks and i
got an opportunity to study the vaders
which are 5000 years old and again we
were put through rigorous study we sat
down we had to learn verses we had to
analyze purports commentaries on ancient
scriptures we had to do comparative
analysis of religions and tradition like
when i was a monk we were massively
trained in philosophical analysis
and that to me gave me a real strength
and confidence in these ideas so some of
the ideas i present today that may sound
simple they're based on these really
ancient deep truths
that i've had the time to
grapple with with the greats who really
understand them
so that to me is a big benefit i've had
where i've had three years
of
complete dedication to studying
philosophy and not just studying the
intellectual areas but the practical and
the applicable areas as well so thanks
to my monk teachers who gave me that
well number nine make your sleep better
can you tell me what you do for sleep
since this was an add-on to the uh time
acronym what's your sleep schedule and
what's your uh do you have a bedtime and
a wake-up routine yeah for sure so
i and so i love ariana's book sleep
revolution too i think it's unbelievable
if you really want to convince yourself
that sleep is important because i think
a lot of us undervalue sleep or we
undervalue sleep before midnight we
undervalue quality sleep we don't
understand what it means and so i think
it's really important and i think she
has a line in there that says something
like this is how you sleep your way to
the top
and she talks about how you know how
successful people can sleep their way to
the tub which i love
but yeah so for me sleep is you know i
for a long time obviously living as a
monk we didn't sleep for long but we
meditate for long periods of time which
kind of created that deep sense of rest
but now that i don't have that i have a
very simple schedule where i sleep by 10
p.m and i'm up at 6 a.m
and i really find that 8 hours and 15
minutes to be exact is like my sweet
time and i've noticed that i've
measured that and i've checked that to
see what works for me because at times
when i had seven to nine hours i was
like all right let me sleep for seven
and get up and be fine and i was
experimenting with seven seven and a
half hours and i found that actually for
me to be in my optimal eight hours and
fifteen minutes is my sweet spot and for
a lot of people they're like wow you're
sleeping a lot that's a lot of time and
i'm like yeah but i'm at my best like
that's what i want why would i want to
sleep seven have an extra hour and 15
minutes but then lose four hours because
i'm unproductive and unhappy and not at
my best that's the opportunity cost that
you have to measure see we're measuring
what could i do with one an hour and 15
minutes my question to you is what's
your energy during that one hour and 15
minutes that you gained from taking it
away from your sleep and and my ability
i believe that the ability to be
productive in less time is more powerful
than to spread it over more time so
i i do that 10 a.m and 6 a.m is when i
wake up usually i've trained myself
after that eight hours 15 minutes i know
that's how much i'm going to sleep so i
don't wake up to an alarm
i really enjoy waking up without an
alarm if you need an alarm because you
and i don't sleep in or snooze in by the
way i'm up at that time because my
body's now used to it but one thing i'd
recommend is don't wake up to your phone
and don't have your phone in your
bedroom before you go to bed so get a
real alarm clock i remember ordering
when i first did this a little timex
alarm clock and i would lock my phone
and my laptop in my car outside so that
i wouldn't even go to them so i would
lock them the night before because it
was so easy for me to just leave my
phone there and so when i wake up in the
morning again i can't look at my phone
my alarm wakes me up and this is one
thing i'd really add
the sound you wake up to
is so important for your mental state
and this is not spoken about enough most
of the sounds that wake up stuff in the
morning whether it's your mom or dad
shouting at you or whether it's a really
annoying alert tone which most phones
have
those are actually shocking you into
being awake you're now waking up with
anxiety and now you're carrying that
anxiety throughout the day waking up to
nature sounds waking up to calming
sounds waking up to the sound of a gong
or symbols or
ocean sounds like sounds like that so
much better for you to wake up to
because imagine literally like
imagine trying you know how many cars
can go from zero to 60 miles per hour in
two to three seconds not many and when
you're putting your foot on the gas like
that with a jolt and a shock
your body's now waking up in shock and
so i would really be careful about the
first thing you see in the morning
and the first thing you hear in the
morning because those two things those
senses are so powerful and rule number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is become more disciplined i
would say my life is purposeful which
has both elements
so so what i mean by that is my life is
easy because i know what i want to do
what i stand for i know what i believe
in but it's difficult because i have to
put in hours i have to put in work i
have to be organized i have to live a
disciplined life
but discipline funnily enough actually
makes life easier so people think
discipline is difficult
but but the result of discipline is that
life becomes easier and so waking up
every day and meditating
or going to the gym is difficult it's
difficult it's not easy it's it's
challenging
but the result of that is life becomes
easier so i'd say that i'm dedicated
to
difficult discipline but that because
it's purposeful and it has meaning
become makes life easier to live if that
answers your question
it does it does but um and i'm asking
you this for selfish reasons because i i
have i have difficult days even today
you know with with so many blessings
around me established businesses there
are days where i'll wake up
not feeling completely motivated slash
not feeling completely worthy uh i'm
just asking you this kind of as a
younger brother oh yeah for sure bro for
sure i still have that i wake up days
where i feel
stressed where i feel
under pressure where i feel
like i've just got so much to do and you
know i haven't got the support i need or
you know all of that like i i experience
all of that
and and what i say to people is that
training your mind and your body
is not about never feeling that way
again it's not that one day that won't
happen
it's that you let it affect you for less
time
so in the past you and me
maybe when it happened when bad things
would happen you'd be thinking about it
for like a whole month
but now when something happens you think
about it for a week
and then in a year from now you'll think
about it for one day and then in a year
from now you'll think about it for one
hour and then a year from now you'll
think about it for one minute and that's
the goal the goal is not to never feel
stress
the goal is to feel it for less and less
time
because
the point is that most of us allow
stress and pressure to consume us
and so the less you let it consume you
is the goal but the problem is that when
you have the goal that i should wake up
and feel perfect every day
that goal puts its own pressure and
stress into your life so i wake up man i
i'm with you like as as you said as a
younger brother which i appreciate you
saying that means a lot to me but as an
older brother like i would say dude i
feel stressed i feel pressure i still
have bad mood swings sometimes
but that's part of it and and that
reminds you how far you have to go
and it keeps you humble and it keeps you
grounded and also it helps you empathize
with people more because if you never
felt that way and then someone tells me
if a young person comes up to me and
says jay i feel stressed and i'm like oh
come on just get over it like there is
no such thing as stress that's not true
and so i find that when i feel stressed
or fearful or anxious
i explore it a little deeper
so that next time someone says that to
me i can actually feel empathy and
compassion for them because i know how
it feels
and so actually i i actually feel like
going through pain is the best thing for
a content creator because that's how you
truly empathize with people if you don't
go through pain then you can never
relate to anyone
we spend away so much energy focusing on
the success of others that we don't
spend enough energy focusing on
developing our own success imagine all
the energy you're channeling towards
someone else's success and just going
how comes they have that and you could
channel them and say actually how do i
create meaningful relationships in my
life how do i create relationships that
i'm happy about just that switch
completely changes the course of your
life right completely that's all the
series that we need to make and that's
the switch where your intelligence leads
the mind rather than the mind leading
the intelligence when the mind leads the
intelligence the mind gets caught in
that web of the mentality that oh i
don't have enough i'm i'm not good
enough and that's one of the interesting
things that
there's no limit on the amount of
holidays you can take there's no limits
on the amount of billionaires in the
world there's no limits on the amount of
millionaires in the world there's no
limits on the amount of successful
people in the world there really isn't
right there's nowhere where it says that
there will only be
a hundred millionaires on this planet
there will only be 10 billionaires on
this planet there aren't rules like that
they're not written anywhere but we tell
ourselves there are we make ourselves
feel that there are so we constantly put
ourselves into this victim mindset where
we feel oh but that doesn't happen to me
that doesn't work for me right that's
not going to happen for me so we need to
remove that and that's the mind leading
when the mind leads it tells us there's
a limit on success there's a limit on
this there's a limit on that if that
person has it i can't have it now that's
not true at all if your friend just went
on a nice holiday to mauritius or
thailand or wherever it is in the world
that doesn't stop you okay you can't
have their seat on the plane that
they're booked given but there's so many
other seats there's so many other
flights and we've got to start
recognizing that we've got to start
connecting with that and that's what we
shift from the mind leading our dialogue
to the intelligence leading our dialogue
the intelligence leads with insight let
me be compassionate towards myself let
me be conscious let me care the mind
leads with impulse or ignorance and
takes us down the wrong route imagine
you've got two friends you're sitting
with two friends right one is the mind
one is your intelligence your
intelligence will be stronger based on
what you read what you absorb that tofu
soaked in your intelligence what you're
taking in every day what you're thinking
about that's when your intelligence gets
stronger it's the one that you feed
right the one that you feed are you
feeding your mind or are you feeding
your intelligence ask yourself that
question right now right how many of you
are feeding your intelligence on a daily
basis versus your mind the one you feed
more gets stronger right the one you
feed more gets stronger the one you feed
with more intensity more absorption gets
stronger i think washing your dishes is
something everyone does every day or
it's a common thing that people do
and
you've got to realize that what you're
doing is not washing the dish like in
terms of that's not actually what you're
doing what you're doing is training your
mind for presence
and the reason why that's so powerful is
because most of us when we're washing
the dishes i need to watch that netflix
show i've got 30 minutes before
you know like i'm gonna sleep late if i
don't see it so now you're already
trying to figure out what you're doing
next
and that bleeds into the rest of your
life
so now when you're finally on that guess
what this is it everyone's going through
quarantine and lockdown going i need to
travel i need to travel i need to get
out
and when you live like that when you're
traveling you'll be thinking i need to
do work i need to get back to work i
need to get my career back on track and
when you're at work you're going to be
like i need to get away again. and
that's literally the repetitive cycle
that we're all living in so when you're
just washing your dish
in a present way you're not washing a
dish you're training your mind to be
where you physically are
and the best way to do that is give it
meaning like you said or
do something that makes you more present
at the time you could if you really
wanted to
wash the dish
and listen to your favorite song you
could watch this and listen to this
podcast you could watch the edition do
something that is good for your mind
that helps you be more present and
conscious at the time so you may say i
don't have enough time to wash the
dishes for 10 minutes like one dish for
10 minutes and i'm not asking you to do
that what i'm saying is
don't constantly be in a rush
to get onto something you want to do
because then when you're doing what you
want to do you'll be in a rush to get on
a thing you have to do
and that cycle never stops and and i
think that's the never-ending cycle that
we're in that we always feel
we're ahead or behind we always feel
we're never where we're meant to be
and that's the root of all of our
suffering in life
is that i don't feel i am where i
actually are meant to be don't settle
like just don't settle
you don't you don't just don't don't
think that you're at the peak of what
you were meant to do
because you probably don't know unless
you try and so for most people i feel
like just don't settle because i think
we just give in too early and
don't settle for service
right it's like that's the reason that's
the intention it's like service is the
one that's pulling you along
and so don't settle for service the
world needs service the world needs your
service the world needs your genius the
world needs your passion
and you just don't know it yet and and
the day you realize it you'll be
grateful that you went the whole way as
as i know we like i feel
i i look back and i'm just like god like
i would have just been sitting there
working in a corporate job and not known
all the people i know now and connected
with this amazing community and met you
i just wouldn't have had it
before if i didn't go for it if i didn't
if i just settled that my service was
this so don't settle for service service
deserves the best of you when i take a
ten thousand foot view
of who you are and what you do it it
seems to me that your your gift or your
your real facility is this ability
this facility for taking
ageless wisdom these spiritual precepts
these philosophical tenets and ideas and
translating them
in
an entertaining way
and a digestible way for a very broad
mainstream and and and perhaps young you
know audience is that fair
sounds good to me yeah no it's you know
it's there was there's a statement by
albert einstein which kind of underpins
all my work and it's
if you can't explain something simply
you don't understand it well enough
and when i was exposed to the evaders
and all these spiritual texts that some
of them date 5 000 years back
i was reading them and i was like there
is magic in these texts like there is so
much energy in these texts there's so
much weight and gravitas and there's so
much power but guess what most people
will never be able to experience it
because it's in another language and
when i say another language i don't just
mean sanskrit or hindi or you know and
you know chinese i mean another language
of it's speaking to a different age
and there's beauty in that and i love
that and and i appreciate that but i
could see that i wanted to try and see
if i could explain these things to
people that i grew up with and i was
always connecting with the person who
grew up in london you know i'm born and
raised in london i grew up liking
anything in average londoners into but i
got so fascinated because of the way the
philosophy was presented to me and i
felt a responsibility to want to do that
for others so yeah i think that's a
that's a pretty good uh breakdown in 10
000 foot view and i and i appreciate you
saying that because that's what
fascinates me that's where i get my buzz
from is how do i read study and learn so
that i can share support and serve and
that's that's where i get my my meaning
from the challenge is that we think
things
come with emotions
feelings we think things come with
feelings and emotions and guess what
they don't so if you chase money well
they might for a moment right or they
won't
i don't think they even do also it's
such a false sense of feeling i don't
maybe for a moment but it's so
short-lived that it's it's not even
worth counting almost so it's like when
you
when you think that i'm chasing money
guess what you will get money yep and
that's great money is really important
and money is a really important resource
but guess what money is not now going to
fill that gap that void that feeling
that emotion that you're missing in your
life what are most people missing
we're missing a deep sense of love i
think i think the biggest need in the
world as we've heard many times before
from all the ancient texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved like that is the need of humanity
to love and be loved and when we don't
experience that we then start looking
for status we then start looking for
money then we then start looking for
recognition just to help us give the
feeling a false sense of love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing what we crave
in life
is what we did or didn't get from our
parents what our parents did give us is
what we continue to crave or what they
didn't give us is what we continue to
crave so you'll find that most people's
love languages that they chase
are things that their parents didn't
give them so if their parents didn't
give them time they now crave everyone's
time if their parents didn't give them
gifts they craved gifts if their parents
didn't give them
acts of service they're craving those
acts of service so it's because of our
childhood
and if we don't learn
to process all of that experience which
most people never get the time to do and
i empathize with that because i've had
to go through that i've seen me
repeating my parents patterns i've seen
something you were craving so i would
crave a big thing for me was i would
crave surprises and gifts because that's
your thing yeah that's my thing still is
your thing they still might be yeah and
and i did your parents not do that for
you no they didn't my mom did a lot of
it that's why you're still quite correct
so my mom would always every year on my
birthday
she'd always surprised me with the one
thing i wanted and i wasn't spoiled
growing up i didn't have a lot growing
up but she would get that one thing
whether it was like a power rangers toy
or whether it was whatever it was you
know something you know yeah the thing
is you won as a kid right and she would
always surprise me with that and that
became so deep rooted now i'll give you
an example when i then married my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're going to do the same thing
totally and tonight
no because i'm expecting my wife to be
like my mom in the sense of i expected a
surprise or show me love in the same way
and she doesn't know that she's not a
mind reader i can't explain expect her
to know that so it took communication it
took time for me to explain that so
anyway i think that's where it stems
from that desire
it doesn't come from any you can say it
comes from society and education of
course it does but i think the deepest
place it comes is what your parents did
or didn't give you that's that's where
it comes from yeah something that
happens is you have to surround yourself
by peers in a space too who understand
you
and don't see you as competition and
that's really hard and it's like a fine
line i genuinely believe that
collaboration wins always
so i my whole approach to most things
has always been hey i want to
collaborate with you whether i'm bigger
on social media or smaller on social
media i'm just like i just want to work
together because i think that's going to
win long term for all of us both not
just in terms of success in numbers but
more in terms of i want to be friends
with you
and so i reach out regularly to people
that i admire in different ways
and i reach out to them and say hey i'd
love to get to know you i'd love to
learn from you i'd love to connect i'd
love to be a friend like not i'd love to
for you to teach me how you do this
and if that comes naturally from that
relationship amazing if it never evolves
into that i've just got a great friend
who now gets me so i try and make
friends in two areas one is in an area
of people who understand my life because
i feel the conversations you can have
with someone who does exactly what you
do
are just so great because they already
get you right
and uh someone that i had on my podcast
lately her name is lily singh superwoman
she's become a recent friend she's been
incredibly and is incredibly successful
on social media she's using her platform
for doing amazing good in the world and
she was someone i reached out to because
i was just like hey like you've been
doing all of this for a while you
started on youtube a lot longer than i
did
and i would just love to connect from
you and hear from you and she's become
an incredible friend
and we've just been sharing ideas and
learning together and it's like that
relationship's awesome and then at the
same time i'm trying to find people who
are not in media so i still have
friendships with the monks back in india
and i just spent january in india for a
month i was meditating again for for
roughly about 21 days
and i have them in my life because they
remind me of like the roots and they
remind me of the truths that bring me
back
so i kind of like both i love people who
totally get my space
and usually those are people i reach out
to
and then i love having my roots down so
most of my inner circle now is from
people i've reached out to
or they've become people who've been
reaching out to me for a long long time
and have been consistently reaching out
to me asking for nothing i've seen some
stories about some phenomenal
paralympians i've seen some phenomenal
stories about human beings who without
arms and legs have achieved
extraordinary feats
and this blows my mind because i always
think like
it's some of us have challenges in
different areas but imagine being born
without legs or arms or you know like
actually not having stuff that we all
take for granted
but those are like
for some people that would be an
absolute dream to have that now through
robotics and bionic limbs they can have
that but for years they've lived without
it but still seen i've seen positivity
in them i've seen driving them i've seen
a desire in them to achieve something
phenomenal so it's amazing what's
happening out there we really have to
connect with those stories rather than
living in our small bubble and often
because we only live in our small bubble
we talk to the same people
right one of the biggest challenges with
envy is that we talk to the same people
and they talk to each other so our group
is so small that we only hear the same
stuff and we kind of start living as if
that bubble of life is real everyone you
love and respect and look up to
that's been their path and i think
that's what's given me so much that's
what's liberated me from it like steve
jobs is one of my biggest
role models in in certain areas of his
life
and when i've read his autobiography's
biography sorry by walter isaacson
it's like the guy has failed so many
times yeah all of us
like most of us have a phone that's an
iphone or an apple product in our home
or whatever it is it's like he's not
worried about all those times that went
wrong because he obviously won big in
this area of his life so my takes just
everyone you look up to whether it's an
athlete an entrepreneur a coach or ceo
whatever it is they have messed up so
many times
i just know that so when you're messing
up you're on the path like you're on the
same path right and and i yeah i
encourage people to share what they're
failing at too
because it just helps i'd say i was
quite rebellious and independent even as
a monk a lot of part of amongst life is
conforming and accepting authority and
following a path and those are all
beautiful things for people
who who like those things for me it was
a great training ground and a great
system of giving me abilities and skills
and habits that i didn't have before but
then i really felt a deep calling in my
heart to want to share this in a
specific way so i i kind of feel dragged
to do what i do now because it's so
deeply in me to want to make things
relevant non-sectarian universal and
accepting of all truths and paths it's
just
it's just there and i can't ignore it
and i got to a point in my monk life or
i just felt like i can't ignore this
desire to want to go and spread this
wisdom and insight in a way
independently in a way that i feel will
work and help people you know from an
impact point of view and so that was a
big part of it i usually write down each
option that i have in life and i think
we all have different options in life
and then i'll place a word above it that
feels like the right emotion so either
it can be fame i could be doing
something just because of ego and fame i
could be doing something out of love
we're doing something for money and
stability i could be doing something for
uh for inspiration and passion so i try
and define
why it's defining that why that
intention behind it like why would i
take that extra flight off to
singapore oh because i'm going to make x
amount of money right like and and
literally when you look at your life
like that yeah yeah there you go and
then i'd be like okay that's a weed now
can i transform it into a seed is there
a way for me to make it more intentional
purposeful and conscious if i can that's
amazing i'll do that but if i can't i
need to stop taking things like that
into my life and now i understand for
anyone listening there are times in our
life where money has to be the motivator
because we need security we need
stability but when you do it
intentionally at least then you don't
expect that thing to bring you the
greatest happiness because you know what
purpose it's serving in your life so i
know a lot of people who'd love to quit
their jobs and live their passion
but i'm like no but you know why if you
know why you're doing the job you're
doing you won't expect it to make you
happy you'll know what it serves
right what role it serves
in shamanism we have this viewpoint that
spirituality is not separate from life
it's it means that someone who's
spiritual even if they don't meditate or
work with crystals or do any of these
things it means they're willing to
evolve i want to know what your thought
is about that
yeah i completely agree i think that's
beautiful and completely aligns with me
i don't think
see we look at everything about oh what
can i learn
and actually half of learning in my
opinion is really unlearning
everyone already has the answer inside
of them
you're not really learning anything new
you're just trying to get rid of all the
bad lessons you learned and everyone has
that so it's not so much about like oh
is this person going from here to here
it's not really that it's like it's
someone going from here to here
and for me one of the ways i've always
thought about is you can't take the
world
further than where you visited
internally
so
for me every person that we're meeting
already has that journey right there
and all you're asking them to do is look
inwards as opposed to outward so no i i
completely agree with you and i think
that's a beautiful point that you've
shared and i think it's something nice
for us to notice that we don't judge and
label people
we don't walk around and think oh those
are spiritual people those are not
spiritual people
because
yeah we're all yeah we're all spiritual
people and it's just that some are
covered it's like the sun's always out
but often it's covered with the clouds
rarely here or a bit more lately
but some it's the sun is always out it
just gets covered by the clouds and
that's us we've just been covered and we
get covered by those clouds and they
cloud our identity they cloud our
perception
and so all we're doing for ourselves and
others is clearing out the clouds
and the more we do that for ourselves
the more we can do it for others and the
more we do it for others the more we do
it for ourselves in 2016 i moved out to
new york so just let me paint a picture
of 2016.
i moved three jobs
i got married wow i moved country
and i
just just started a whole new life like
my life just transformed so we went to
all of that with my wife in one year and
by the way all of that was surprises the
job chains were surprises yeah the
country change was a surprise the
marriage was not a surprise we played
everything
was a surprise now i said i like
surprises so i can roll with it but my
point is that's a lot of transition so
much transition and i felt the burden
of being in a new city where we had no
family we had no friends
and my wife who loves being around her
family and no one understands just how
close she is to them i felt this burden
on me
that i had taken away her time with her
family and now she was alone so i was
going out to work and she'd be crying at
home
and i was thinking she's got no friends
she's got no support and i know you can
relate to this with moving and
relationships and so much going on and
so it's like i'm dealing with that and
guess what six months later i have to
leave and move on and
work on a new career to build everything
myself and then i'm four months away
from being broke
and so on top of all of this i've now
got four months away from being broke
i've got enough money money saved for
four months to pay for rent and
groceries and that's it in new york city
and that's it and guess what even on top
of that i've got 30 days before my visa
runs out and i'm kicked out of the
country so i can't even live here
anymore
so not only have i just got married
moved job three times changed career
again had to move into apartment four
months of being broke and i might get
kicked out in 30 days and my renewal for
my visa costs fifteen thousand dollars
so that's gonna eat into those four
months
i have probably never been under that
much emotional
physical and and mental pressure in my
life like genuinely i felt it and i
thought my body changed my my breath was
more stressed i would be breathing
faster shorter breaths not deep breaths
heartbeating faster not working out you
get into lazy habits you start craving
junk food you have energy i'm living in
a 500 square foot apartment with my wife
which is which is tiny like everything's
in that space and guess what we both
work from home so i'm now sitting at a
desk hunched over trying to figure stuff
out she's trying to cook in the same
room like i'm trying to just just trying
to figure out what to do and i remember
the next morning
sending like a hundred emails to people
and just being like this is who i am
this is what i can do how can we serve
and that was the same year that i ended
up meeting you later in that year
and the beginning three months of that
journey was so stressful like they were
so stressful because i was like what if
i have to move back to london
what am i gonna say to her parents i
mean i just took their daughter away
like uh
just got married i've lived in new york
city for six months and my life's
falling apart like you know so much and
i've got all these views but there's
nothing there's nothing happening here
we met you also you also i mean at this
time you're also
growing so much how are you able to
create and reach this impact with your
videos that's growing while you're under
so much stress and uncertainty and i
stopped a bit at that time like things
slowed down like things slowed down i
remember i wasn't crying as much as i
was because i don't enjoy creating from
stress or pressure and i don't think you
can really create something from stress
and pressure so we really slowed down at
that time and when i was creating i was
creating from a place of recognizing
that i could share what i had learned
and what i had grown in so far so
anything i was sharing was like this is
what i've learned so far so that was the
biggest pain that i've been through in
the last seven years for sure
and all i can say is that i remember
coming home to my wife knowing that this
was going to be the truth and i came and
i said to i said to her i guarantee you
this is going to be the best thing that
ever happened to us what the pain the
pain i said that to the night i came
home and then she gave after i literally
came up i looked in the eyes and got
this is the scenario
and i just want you to know that i
guarantee to you this is the best thing
that's ever going to happen to us and i
said this is this is a monk statement
that we used to repeat i said to her i'm
just not going to judge the moment
don't judge the moment because what we
do is we try to label moments as good or
bad and when you label the moment as bad
it now does not have the opportunity to
become good i'll give an example if i go
i don't like this book this book's bad
right and i don't and i love this video
but if i say that guess what i will
never pick it up and recognize the value
that's inside of it because you've
labeled it yes and we label stuff like
we label oh that restaurant's bad
but when you label them emotions that
person's bad now you can't learn from
that person oh a great one that's a
really good one
as soon as you start labeling people or
anything is good or bad you limit it you
stop it from being something else and
here's the truth
every moment can evolve into being
anything if you give it the opportunity
to right but as soon as you say it's got
no value anymore you lose it
and so for me i had to say to myself
don't judge the moment and i'd keep
repeating that don't judge where you're
at don't judge what's happening yeah
don't judge it as negative don't don't
just start saying it's negative because
guess what we've all been in positions
where a gift turned into a curse and a
curse turned into a gift it's true right
we've always our dreams came true and it
ended up not being what we wanted
exactly it fell apart and it led us into
the our dream totally why is it that so
many people that win the lottery yeah go
broke yeah gifts can turn into curses
too but because we label them as the
best moment in our life or the worst
moment in our life whereas when you
approach things to neutrality and just
what you have on the table you can be
like okay what am i going to do next how
many of you spend a lot of your days
multitasking
okay good
so a lot of us spend our time
multitasking now studies show that
only two percent of us
are actually able to multitask
and when most people hear that they're
like yeah i'm in that two percent
that's me right i'm in that two percent
uh you're probably not i'm not because
it's only two percent of the global
population of the world multitasking is
a myth
and i find that as spiritual activists
as conscious change makers as change
agents of the world whatever you want to
call yourself
all of us one of the biggest mistakes
we've seen and this was the quote that i
shared and a thought from martin luther
king that i've really held close to me
is he said those who love peace
need to learn to organize themselves
as well as those who love war
right those who love peace need to learn
to organize themselves as well as those
who love war i.e people are trying to
build
destruction in the world and
distractions in the world are highly
organized highly focused
highly data oriented highly strategic
highly process driven
and so we have to be the same and when
you spend time with vision you spend
time with the mind valley team you
realize their success is intuitive it is
deep it is full of love but it is also
highly strategic it is also highly
focused and therefore it's effective
and so for me
my plea to all of you and to myself is
whatever we're going to do let's get
really strategic about it
let's bring sincerity and strategy
together
let's bring data and dynamism together
let's bring intuition and insight
together
right let's not let's not look beyond
that and think oh that stuff's going to
work out because i intend my intention's
nice
right your intention's not gonna run a
mile
but it will help you run the marathon
but it's not gonna run that mile that
you need to do right now and so for me
intention and action intention and
attention both of them are required and
so my recommendation is whatever your
dream is whatever you're inspired by
whatever you think is going to have a
positive impact on the world bring both
to that right don't settle for one or
the other one of the biggest mistakes we
make is that we confuse inexperience
with being unqualified
so because we've not tried a lot of
things we just naturally believe that we
can't be that good at them so if i've
never spoken on a stage i just think oh
i'm probably not good at that or if i've
never played golf i'd probably think i'm
probably not good at that and so we
start writing off things without even
trying them so the best method i can
share with someone is take the next
month
take the next four weekends in the month
that gives you eight days
and get really tactical every single day
that's why you're playing tennis a lot
right now yeah
take the eight days
go join a course an online course or
workshop go and shadow a friend go to a
seminar or a conference go to reading a
book listen to podcasts go and expose
yourself to eight different things in a
month eight different things eight
different things in a month and guess
what in a month you will have learned
what you probably would have learned in
eight years because most of us test one
new thing a year maybe maybe if that
exactly right like some people don't
even do that but if you do eight
different things in a month and this is
how you have to see it if you went to
eight different restaurants in a month
you ask yourself after you eat a meal
like i had that burrito or i had that
taco did i like it right the first
question you asked yourself is did i try
it first you got to try it first you got
to go to the restaurant yeah there's no
point so you're going to say did i like
it
the second question you ask yourself is
why did i or why did i not like it
like why is so important i think too
many people just go i like it or i don't
like it why didn't i like and the third
question you have to ask yourself really
really simple is do i want to do it
again
and if you do
that's where you start uncovering is so
my point is inexperience do not
misinterpret inexperience for a lack of
qualification and we actually
is more of a
expression of how we feel about
ourselves rather than how we're
perceiving someone else it's actually so
much more about how comfortable we feel
with who we are how confident who we
feel with who we are how much
self-esteem we have how much
self-assurance we have enemy is more a
root of that than it is of the fact that
someone else is doing well it's less
about the fact that someone out there is
amazing making waves doing something
that you want to be doing it's more
about how we feel about ourselves and
it's experienced
in that way of looking at someone else
and reflecting back on us social circles
family circles someone else has done
amazingly in their exams someone just
landed a new job someone else just got
promoted and everyone's looking at you
going what are you doing right what have
you achieved where are you today where
have you got right what's happening with
you tell us about you
and you're thinking you know you're
going through all your head you're
trying to come up with all the things
that you've thought about all the things
that you've achieved all the things that
you've done and you're trying to bring
it up like constantly but you're
struggling you find it hard because
you're now measuring your growth
based on someone else's you're now
measuring your success based on someone
else's and that is the
biggest challenge with envy that one of
the biggest challenges it brings in our
life is that it forces us to start
measuring our sex
sorry our success in comparison to
someone else's that is the biggest
challenge with envy
when we start comparing the level of our
success with someone else's you're
already on the wrong foot i really
believe that everything we say
that beautiful thought from gandhi where
he said that when what you think what
you say and what you do are in line then
you'll experience harmony and and i've
really taken that to heart and it's it's
this powerful spiritual principle and it
really means you think what you say and
what you do are aligned
and so for me any form of language any
form of your emotional vocabulary is
building your mental reality and i think
people forget that their vocabulary is
defining their life you are creating
your life on a daily basis by the words
you use so for me and i'm not saying
that i feel that way about everyone else
i'm saying that's how i feel about that
word someone may say oh when i say swear
word it makes me laugh for me it doesn't
that i would only swear when i
felt
bad and i felt something negative
towards something so for me that had
negative emotions negative connotations
and negative uh intention attached to it
so i wanted to remove anything from my
vocabulary that i felt was negative so
even as simple as and i've done this
very recently but it's changed my life
instead of me saying i'm busy or it's
been a busy week i say i'm having a
productive week and i feel different
when i go to bed just by that simple
change i go to bed thinking yeah i've
had a really productive day today rather
than going god i had a busy day today i
don't want to wake up tomorrow i'm going
to have a busy day tomorrow and so that
simple emotional vocabulary change has
just
catapulted my mind into feeling excited
and enthusiastic all the time i start
off the chapter with this beautiful
thought from charles horton cooley and i
love telling it because it's just it's
just the best and i think it was written
in like the 1900s and he said today the
challenge is i'm not what i think i am
i'm not what you think i am
i am what i think you think i am it's
crazy man and it's like it blows my mind
every time i say it gives me the chills
like i feel it and the reason why i
start with identity is because i think
that's the root of all our challenges
and the first step to thinking like a
monk is starting at the root not
starting at the symptoms or the
superficial or the surface level but
let's go to the root
if you're playing a role if you're
wearing a mask
if you're dressed in clothes that are
not yours
then you end up living a life that's not
yours and in the book i give this
example of method acting yes
yeah amazing i'm a massive movie
junkie and i love method actors so
people like heath ledger of course from
the dark knight series you've got jared
leto so jared leto when he played the
joker in this is not in the book in
suicide squad he used to send dead rats
in the mail to his co-stars
he did because he was trying to get into
the mindset of how someone that
perverted would behave
and then daniel dave lewis when he was
filming for gangs of new york he's
actually wearing these coats that are
centuries old so that he can get into
character while he's off camera yeah
when he can feel it right he's not
wearing watches he's not carrying around
his mobile phone they're speaking in the
accents and he talks about how he
actually went crazy because guess what
when you fake being someone for so long
you think it's your reality
and that's what happens to all of us we
play a role at work we play a role at
home we play a role with our family we
play a role at our friends and then we
think that role is us right and we lose
ourselves and to me that is the core
reason why we're chasing things that are
not important to us
we always have been trained to focus on
the results so people ask what do you
want in life and i'm like forget that
that's the worst question to ask someone
because when you ask what you want
that's when the ads come in and you're
like oh i want that car i want that home
i want that dress i want that body i
want whatever it is
i my question to is what do you want to
wake up and be every day like what do
you want to wake up and do every day
what's the process that you're in love
with
so we're thinking about the result
whereas my question is forget the result
what's the process that you're in love
with doing
so start there first of all don't start
your journey of saying i want to be a
movie director because i want to you
know i want to hit the blockbuster chart
so i want to do this don't make it about
that like don't don't be like i want to
be a singer because i want to be ariana
grande right like that's not the point
that's just a result
do you love singing every day and i
realize this with a very honest question
to myself i'm really passionate about
football soccer i absolutely love the
game i grew up on it i'm still a huge
fan i missed out on it when i was a monk
i've been catching up ever since like
i'm like oh any football game i was just
in london last week and i made sure i
went i didn't see a game live but i went
and watched it at a bar in london and i
love the energy i'm so passionate about
soccer
i don't have what it takes to be a
soccer player yeah like i do not want to
wake up at 4 00
i wake up at 4 a.m to meditate when i
was a monk i wake up at 6 00 5 30 am now
to meditate
i do not want to wake up at 4am to go
out on a reigning pitch and play soccer
like i don't want to be in the gym for
four hours a day i want to meditate for
four hours a day but i don't want to me
play soccer for four hours a day and
then be in the gym and train i'm not
envious of
any athlete in the world because it
takes a different type of mindset i was
really shy i didn't enjoy stages i
didn't enjoy speaking my parents forced
me to go to public speaking and drama
school so i spent 14 to 18 in public
speaking drama school changed my life i
did not know what i wanted to speak
about so even when i finished at 18 i
still didn't like going on stage because
i didn't have anything to talk about so
now you've got the tools but you haven't
got the passion so i developed somewhat
of an expertise in four years but i
didn't have what i was passionate about
and when i became a monk
i was like this is it this is why i went
to public speaking school because i love
talking about philosophy i love talking
about science i love talking about
culture i love talking about
life i love talking about growth etc the
mind so i got what i was passionate
about when i became a monk
so for me the process came from four
years
of consistent public speaking school
like it changed my life
and and that's all thanks to my parents
for forcing me to go i had no interest
in being a public speaker or a
storyteller any of these things that was
just i lucked out
and then it was me finding what i was
passionate to speak about and then i've
spoken i've spoken for three hours a day
for the last 13 years
and i spoke to audiences of xero
all the way to audiences now of
thousands but when i first started
speaking i remember i was invited to
speak at a university where i wasn't
getting paid for i was like 20 years old
i was invited to speak to this
university no one showed up
twice
so they organized two events for me i
was meant to speak about life philosophy
etc all the kind of stuff i speak about
now and zero people turned up and i
practiced my speech both times to an
empty room as if it was a packed room
because i was like i'm still gonna
practice and so for me having done this
for three hours a day for the last 13
years
that's
now being
gratefully received online so i'm very
fortunate that it's shifted from an
offline world to an online world which
we can dive into but the point is it's
it's been my absorption and addiction
for like
for over a decade now in the hope for
money in the hope for success we end up
chasing the wrong things and we make a
mess we end up with less than we started
with end up with more issues than we
bargained for whilst climbing that
ladder and that stairway we forget why
we started climbing in the first place
once the king of bhutan was asked by an
interviewer what the gdp of bhutan was
he was surprised and shocked
he replied by saying in bhutan we don't
just measure the gdp
we measure the gnh instead of just
measuring the gross domestic product
we measure gross national happiness in
the process of getting older we forget
the real goal of life
if you could make a little less and
spend more time doing what you love
would that make you happier
don't trade your happiness for what you
think you need
things can never make us happy because
they're temporary and limited
but experiences can last forever too
many people are working hard on things
they don't love to spend money they
don't have to buy things they don't need
to impress people they don't like
when we create our identity or on what
we do a career a job an occupation we
can never be happy because we're basing
it on something external but when we
create an identity around who we are and
what we want to be and become
then anything is possible and remember
we become successful by what we get
but we become happy by what we give
don't get the two confused
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there